planning a trip to washington
make sure you have your copy of c-span's
exploring the capitol a self-guided tour
through the halls of congress
in its pages you'll learn the history
meet the people and discover the
architecture of this national landmark
to charge your copy of exploring the
capital call toll-free
1-800-523-3174 or send a check or money
order for 5.95
plus two dollars shipping and handling
to exploring the capital c-span
publications
1616 main street
lynchburg virginia
the zip code is 24504
this is book notes c-span 60-minute
discussion with the authors of public
policy historical and political works
for the next hour you'll see behind the
titles and gain insight into the authors
as people and the experiences which
shape their lives
[Music]
this week our guest is lawyer economist
and author benjamin stein he joins us to
discuss his book a license to steal the
untold story of michael milken and the
conspiracy to build the nation
[Music]
benjamin j stein author of a license to
steal the untold story of michael milken
and the conspiracy to build the nation
why'd you write this book
well i had been studying this subject
for five or six years it struck me as a
scandalously
bad scam
and it struck me that no one had told
the story i had told the story in bits
and pieces and some overview in barons
but there was no book explaining what
milken had done wrong it is it was on
everybody's mind on everybody's tongue
that he was a convicted junk bond
swindler but nobody exactly knew what he
had done
and none of the books that had come out
had really explained what he had done so
i thought it was worthwhile for the
american people to know about the worst
financial
fraud in history as far as i can tell
you open the book by standing in a
building not too far from here right on
wilshire boulevard and rodeo in the
heart of beverly hills and
i went over there the day that drexel
the day after drexel declared bankruptcy
and uh i wanted to see the building
they wouldn't let me in of course and uh
they still had the drexel guards there
and a real estate agent i knew
took me around and showed me the
property because they were trying to
lease it milken owns the building never
one to waste a chance to make a few
dollars
he uh wanted to lease out the space
immediately and i
was shown around it was a dismal site it
was empty and barren
and a lot of the building had never even
been finished it was very very valuable
space but they were making so much money
off the junk bond racket that they
hardly needed to worry about renting a
few floors until the junk brand racket
failed one of the most amazing things
that happened on that day was one of the
guards at the door
was complaining bitterly to another
guard and also to me
that
milken himself had persuaded this guard
to buy stock in first executive a drexel
captive insurance company and the stock
had just gone down to nothing and the
man had lost much of his life saved nsa
said to me where's mike now when's your
first meet mike milk
i only met him once although i have the
feeling i'd seen him coming in and out
of morton's but i only which is a
restaurant here but i met him when i
first moved to la and i was working for
norman lear
drexel had an office
down the hall in 1901 avenue the stars
and i saw a sign on it for a long time
it didn't have any sign then it had a
sign saying something like drexel
burnham lambert high yield securities i
had a tiny amount of savings and i
thought yeah i'd like to get a high
yield so i went in there
i told them which was truthful that i
wrote occasionally for the wall street
journal and that i was also interested
in this subject and they uh
they showed me around a little bit and
then
milken came out and started to explain
about them and the explanation was
extremely unconvincing but frankly i put
it out of mind for at least 10 years i
mean it didn't really occur to me that
this explanation had been so
unconvincing and it didn't occur to me
that this was connected in some way with
the essential fraud of the entire scheme
you point out in your book which was
when was the last word written
of the book yeah
oh maybe four or five months ago you i
as you read through the book you keep i
saw you keep anticipating that by the
time this book comes out in early 93 he
may be free
out were you sure that he was going to
be free at that point oh yeah oh sure
because first of all the judge had
reduced his sentence from 10 years to
two years i think that was a unfortunate
on her part but she had done so and i
knew that he wouldn't serve even the
full two years i mean the guy is just so
wired it's impossible for him to ever
be the subject of justice in the way
that anybody else would so it would i
anticipate that he would be in fact i
anticipate that he would be out before
now i had anticipated he would get out
of thanksgiving why did you feel so
strongly about this
well i feel very badly when people steal
huge sums of money from ordinary
citizens or take them unethically it's a
society which is built on trust i'm
i write about this a lot it's real
important to me it seems to me what
differentiates america from other
countries is essentially we are a
society of laws we believe we have laws
that govern the rich the middle class
and the poor blacks and whites jews and
gentiles
and this was a case in which a whole
alternative financial empire had been
created in defiance of law in defiance
of economics in defiance of all the
principles that make this country great
and on top of that
this this empire had co-opted some of
the most important commentators and
academics in the field and had them say
that this man was doing great things
when he was really running a gigantic
fraud and this was i thought an
extremely unfortunate
event to have happen and did not go
commented upon i mean
this this the the milken fraud
represents a titanic failure of public
policy a titanic failure of law
enforcement a titanic failure of ethics
a titanic failure of journalism of
academic probity and as far as i could
tell no one was summarizing it and
putting it all together and yet it was
an enormous story it seems to me it is
by far the biggest financial story
private financial story that there's
ever been in america and it was not
getting out except in barons
what is barron's barons is a weekly
financial
magazine and a very very wonderful one
it's edited by a great man named alan
abelson and
managing edited by another great man
named jim moore who owns it it's owned
by dow jones who reads it
it's read by uh several hundred thousand
people who really care about finance the
joke around
barons is it's read by the retired
accountant with five million dollars to
invest but it's read by actually a great
many people have money to invest
barons if i may make this plug for them
since they've been very nice to me
although i don't i'm a freelancer i
don't work for them
barons as far as i know is the only
magazine published for the investor as
opposed to the people who sell
investments
the other financial magazines which
shall be nameless i think exist mainly
as platforms for the touting of the sale
of investments whereas barons really
cares about the investor how long did
mike milken spend in jail 22 months
how much i figure is about one month for
every billion that his firm unethically
took from american savers and taxpayers
what jail was he in he was in one
pleasant and pleasant and federal
correctional facility which is in the
bay area the san francisco bay area and
uh it's
no one would want to be in prison i
certainly would not want to be in prison
but as prisons go it's a country club
you have a picture in your book it looks
like a dorm room i went to columbia
college in new york and i must say it's
a heck of a lot nicer room that he had
there at pleasanton than i had at
columbia did you try to interview him
for this book yes i tried to interview
him repeatedly and was never allowed to
do that at first i would be turned down
in a very polite way by steve and redder
who was the drexel publicist and then i
was turned down in a less than
polite way by his personal milken's
personal publicist you point out the
steam anne redder used to work for
barons yes
and and although i
although i quarreled with him repeatedly
and uh i don't believe he was really
giving the straight scoop about what was
going on at drexel bike by a long long
way
he was a heads-up player the the people
who replaced him were a nightmare
who is benjamin j stein
i am benjamin j stein
i am not just a person you used to be a
person
where were you born i was born in
washington dc
your nation's capital grew up in the
suburbs in silver spring maryland a
wonderful place which i visit frequently
went to a wonderful high school there
montgomery blair which i
go to all the reunions i've been even i
have to fly there from california and uh
went to columbia in new york and then to
yale law school was there roughly the
same time as bill clinton and at exactly
the same time for one year as hillary
rodham clinton do you know them well i
met her i don't think i've ever met him
i've met her well she was a very uh
shy quiet little student when uh when
she was at yale but obviously she had a
dynamic personality waiting to come out
what'd you do after yale
well i was a poverty lawyer for the
office of legal services of the office
of economic opportunity where i actually
worked with some interesting people
terry lenzner who later became a lawyer
for milken and a very capable aggressive
hard-working fellow named mickey cantor
who's become a big gigantic democratic
powerhouse and is now going to be
special trade representative
and then i worked as a
lawyer at the federal trade commission
trial lawyer that was a very hard job
it really gave me a taste for how
dangerous over regulation is
then i uh worked as a t i worked as a
teacher at american university in
washington dc fabulous job it was a
fabulous job worked as a teacher at uc
santa cruz which is the most beautiful
town in america and i consider myself
if that was the only thing i'd ever done
in my life i would consider it a gift
from god it was just magnificent
then i was a speech writer for president
nixon and then briefly for president
ford that was a great job that whatever
anyone may say about the nixon people
they were to me the nicest people i've
ever worked with in my life
then i worked with with and for bob
bartley as a columnist and editorial
writer at the wall street journal
editorial page
i'm a great great fan of bob bartlett i
don't think he got this story about
milken quite right but he really
deserves a lot of kudos from the
american people for some of his
accomplishments in preserving freedom
then i uh came out here i wrote a couple
of great many books actually that here
is where oh southern california center
of the universe los angeles center of
the universe the original in the xerox
machine of mass culture as i like to say
and then i and i've been a writer of
books
a teacher of law
a
actor writer of screenplays but mostly
for the last six or seven years a reader
and student of financial fraud
how many movies have you been in
oh gosh i don't know seven or eight
maybe
i can remember seeing you pop up for 15
seconds in a couple of those movies well
and well brian and a couple of them i
was in for two or three minutes but my
usual scene is quite short i i've had a
long scene which was a classic and
ferris bueller's day off where i played
a boring economics teacher and i didn't
even think i was that boring but they
thought i was boring
the people who made the picture when i
when i finished doing the scene which i
ad-libbed entirely as i made up all of
it entirely
the uh
the the stars of the picture real
real people real stars matthew broderick
and and uh leah thompson i guess maybe
this matthew broder came up to me and
said wow i love your work have you ever
done any work on broadway well that was
the first time i'd ever done
any real work except for a few seconds
in another movie and the idea of calling
acting work
just amazes me because it's like calling
uh
i don't know what it would be called
like be calling sex work it'd be like
calling eating a fabulous piece of tuna
fillet work i mean
acting is god's gift acting as bliss
reading about junk bond default rates
reading long tomes about junk bond of
all rights that's work
acting is not work why did you move out
here
i moved out here because i wanted to
write a book about the political and
social and cultural
content of primetime television i had
been out here by courtesy of the wall
street journal several times and i had
written a number of articles about how
the political content of what's on prime
time
was dictated not by what the public was
thinking
not by what the public was wanting but
by the mindset the political views of a
very few dozen people who control prime
time very few very powerful writers
producers and network executives
and that these people are essentially
quite anti-business
anti-military
anti-suburb and anti-rural
a very pro-minority pro-old people
a kind of classic liberal left viewpoint
of the world and that i interviewed
several dozen these people and found
that their views coincided precisely
with what was on tv and i wrote a book
about that
then i wrote another book and also i had
been asked to consult with norman lear
he had a show about
which had a conservative speech writer
living with a liberal
liberal photographer she was played at
bernadette peters
and he asked me to consult about that so
i did that
i was paid 600 a week which the most was
the most i'd ever been paid and i
thought i was i really thought i was as
rich as a rockefeller
and
so
i did that and then i helped invent a
show called fernwood tonight which is a
very very funny show
what do you think of this part of the
world i love la la is still as far as
i'm concerned the center of the universe
it's gone through some very difficult
changes
it's got a lot of scary people in it now
that didn't have quite as many of before
there's a lot of bad gangs and
the the situation in terms of
gang shootings is just out of control
and very scary but it doesn't really
knock wood affect people in the west
side of town where i live as much as i
as much as in the other parts of town i
love it it's a place of opportunity it's
a place where everything is mobile
unfixed flexible achievable doable
when i watch the clinton people when i
watch the bush people
i'm just awfully awfully glad that i
live here where i don't have to be part
of a company town there's all kinds of
different opportunities for variations
on the theme i love hollywood i mean
hollywood is a very forgiving open
wonderful place it's uh
in l.a all together is like that i mean
i
i'm privileged to have a house in malibu
i can't really afford it but i have it
and as i'm doing my dishes i don't have
a dishwasher as i'm doing my dishes
looking at the ocean
i feel awfully lucky i mean
i could be just looking at a brick wall
i could be looking at somebody's
backyard i'm awfully awfully lucky to
live where i do you dedicate this book
to alex tommy and trixie
alex is my permanent wife
she's so we've been
divorced separated over several times
but
i consider her my wife for life no
matter what our legal status is
are you married to her now we're
separated now but uh and but we're uh
we had one time executed a holistic
a holistic divorce which was which he
just wrote out we were divorced but uh i
will i intend to be in one guise or
another married or for all eternity not
just for this lifetime but for all
eternity
and uh i uh my uh tommy is my son the
world's cutest human he's five years old
he's the world's cutest human
and trixie is my dog
how long have you been married alex
well off and on since 1968
it's sometimes off sometimes on
now
you know that when you say these kind of
things that people want to know
what's this all about off and on up and
down but you're going to be married to
her for eternity what what's the word i
have not been legally married to her
since i was we were married divorced
remarried and separated for
quite a long time how long how many
times you've been married to her and
divorced
twice but i intend
to
to be married to her when i die at the
time i die whatever that whatever that
is
god willing and i intend to spend
eternity with her where'd you meet her i
met her at the state department at a
party of foreign junior foreign service
officers ball on july 4th 1966 and i'd
never seen anyone so beautiful in my
entire life i was with a date a girl
who's a very very fine woman
actually a high honcho of the clinton
regime
at this point and a very very fine human
being but i saw this woman across the
room with a fellow who's also kind of a
high clinton knight type now they think
of it
and i just had never seen anyone like
her i thought this girl is fantastically
beautiful
she's probably like nobody could be this
beautiful and also smart i remember
thinking to myself but then it turned
out she was incredibly smart she was a
student at vassar college and very very
smart what does she do now
well she is uh like me a dog fancier but
she is a she is the mother
she is also a
lawyer she was a lawyer for a long time
at paramount and she was head of legal
at united artists
and
she's
she's a saint as her basic occupation
she's a saintly person there's a picture
in the back of the book of you uh on the
flap that we'll see on the screen in
just a moment uh there's a lot of dogs
in there i see a dog in your lap that's
your chocolate that's trixie you got a
dog on your tie
that's also trixie how do you know
i remember having a tie made in trixie's
image and there's a dog
one more shot here there's a dog behind
you on the on the wall that's mary my
first dog who was given to me by a
wonderful girl named pat who is not a
high clinton official
but who is in washington and uh i just
love dog dogs are everything if you if i
had to
choose how to
spend the balance of my life in perfect
serenity i think it would be just me and
some dogs lying in bed watching tv
you um but i have to work on junk bonds
too because it's my social duty we'll
get back to this book in a moment uh
herbert
stein a stone genius who is herbert he's
my father he's a a
genius economist writer and wit
and in the back of the acknowledgement
she called him your brilliant father he
insisted that i write about milken in
terms of economic theory especially
price fixing and this really explained
everything
because
drexel was really the money machine that
it was because milken was able to fix
the price of bonds most sellers of bonds
underwriters of bonds deal in a highly
competitive market they would get a tiny
percentage of the bonds value for
underwriting them and selling them let
me interrupt what's a bond a bond is a
promise to pay a certain sum of money at
a certain rate of interest
over time that is if a bond is evidence
of indebtedness it is evidence that
the bond issuer has borrowed money from
someone and will repay it with a certain
amount of interest over a certain period
of time so when you walk in that voting
booth and you see up there bonds are
being floated by counties and cities
that's what you're talking about yes but
except milken did actually work in that
area as well but he mostly worked in
corporate bonds
he would raise money for corporate
borrowers but because he could fix the
market price at which the bonds were
sold
and because he could sell bonds that no
one else could sell
he could create a capture a fantastic
commission for underwriting these bonds
for example if morgan stanley a very
much more reputable although not
perfectly reputable investment bank
issued bonds for say ge it might get a
quarter percent
but if milken issued them for the
schmeckless corporation which nobody had
ever heard of he gets four percent plus
he would probably get equity kickers
plus you get the promise of the people
around the schmeckless corporation that
they would use a sizable percentage of
that money to buy other bonds
for the reckless corporation or the
techless corporation or some other
corporation in real life
then they're often savings and loans and
insurance companies and our casino
companies is is this hard for the
average person understanding not at all
it's the exact same concept as if
general motors
instead of selling chevrolets so they
had to compete with fords plymouths
hondas
and toyotas could charge anything it
wanted for chevrolets and people had to
buy them
the the beauty of the milken scheme and
what made it so incredibly powerful was
that milken controlled both sides of the
deal he controlled both the
lenders and the borrowers he controlled
the lenders because he controlled a huge
network of federally insured snls and of
very good size insurance companies and
of junk bond funds so for example
if you brian lamb said i am starting the
brian lamb corporation we're going to uh
market
fishing tackle nobody's ever heard of us
but i'd really like to raise 200 million
dollars please mr milken and he would
say first of all call me mike and then
he'd say
well of course we can do it i'm
summarizing this for you i didn't i'm
not really quoting him for a bit he'd
say here's what we'll do we'll take your
100 million and we'll actually raise 120
million for you
and you would say to him but mr milken i
don't think my bond my company will be
able to support more than say 60 million
i don't think we can pay the interest on
more than 60 million he would say in
effect no problem boychick here's what
we're going to do we'll raise the 120
million
you will use some of that excess 60
million to continue servicing the bonds
to continue paying the interest on the
bonds
in the meantime you'll take other parts
of it other parts of the money i've
raised for you and you'll buy bonds in
the ben stein corporation and those will
pay a very high coupon and those will
use that money to pay off the coupon on
your bones and you would say but mr
milken or mike who will buy my bonds i'm
a complete unknown in this field he
would say well columbia savings because
the head of columbia savings tom spiegel
is my best bud
and
centrust in florida because david paul
the head of centrist is my best bud and
lincoln savings because charles keating
in arizona is my one of my best buds and
uh first executive because fred carr the
head of first executive insurance
company is my very very best bud and uh
we'll get them sold don't you worry
about selling you pay me four percent i
get equity kickers that is i get stock
in the company in large quantities and
will and leave the rest to me
um
one of the reasons we do this show is to
do books on public policy this is a
public policy issue and the connection
here as you read through your book you
see reference to the securities and
exchange commission you see reference to
the justice department
you see reference to john dingell's
committee on capitol hill
john dingle's committee are heroes in
this context they're one of the only
people who paid any attention to this
whole phenomenon
the sec charged with enforcing the
securities laws completely totally
dropped the ball on this
i think this is a national scandal and i
really think there should be a special
prosecutor
appointing to investigate this whole
subject but you made some connections
there
well john shad who is head of the sec
during most of the reagan years
is a former stock broker and investment
banker who was best friends or very
close friends with fred joseph who was
the chairman of the board of drexel
milken was really running drexel but
fred joseph was the chairman of the
board and he was endlessly endlessly
endlessly pals and buddies with fred
joseph even when there was a lot of
evidence kicking up that drexel was not
quite an above board player and he would
never allow any kind of full-bore
prosecution or even full-bore
investigation of drexel or never
facilitated let us say it is amazing
that with all the laws on the books
about requirements of full disclosure
requirements that there not be any
schemes or devices to defraud investors
drexel
entirely built on lack of full
disclosure entirely built on fraud was
never really gone after by the sec and
still has not been gone after by the fcc
this is something which every large
player on wall street knows in his bones
happen i have spoken to many many big
powers on wall street well-known names
on wall street and they said of course
it happened just like you said of course
it was a ponzi of course it was a fraud
of course the bonds could never pay off
at the way the way they were promised to
pay off everybody knew it
at least they knew it for the last few
years they didn't know it all the time
but for the last few years the sec never
went after it it is a shame i would say
it it verges upon criminal dereliction
of duty i won't say by any specific
person but for the agency in general
virtually criminal dereliction of duty
six billion dollars left
i think that milken would have roughly
five or six billion left now this where
well i don't know uh a friend of mine
who is a state insurance
state securities commissioner for
colorado and writes funny songs about
securities law
yes that's true um has made up a song
about this which goes to the tune of
michael roe the bow to shore which has
to do with michael
atlantic ocean is deep and wide
michael's money on the other side
but that's a uh that's just a guess i
don't know where it is i mean people say
people come to me and tell me about
stories about it being in switzerland
and germany and the cayman islands and
the bahamas i don't know where it is by
my calculations he would have taken in
five or six billion
and uh
buy my account he would have put that at
interest he wasn't just going to put it
under his bed and encino uh he's had to
pay out
about a billion and a half
in the meantime he's earned money
interest on that other money and uh he's
had very very large legal and public
relations fees
but uh he would still have several
billion left i think it's hard to
imagine he would have less than that
left you mentioned bob bartley the
editorial i mean the editor of the wall
street journal runs the editorial page
you say a lot of nice things about him
in here but you say he missed it on this
whole story and you name a lot of other
journalists that missed it anybody get
it
well there was a journalist at the san
diego union who got it nobody's ever
heard of him but uh he gone what's his
name i don't even remember his name
michael thomas
a very very smart guy who writes for the
new york observer and who writes books
god he didn't get it in detail but he
certainly got that it was a scam he's a
terribly important observer of the
financial scene
my father and i got it and a number of
people on wall street and a number of
lawyers in the field got it but as far
as i'm aware the financial journalism
community completely missed it and
it's really very unfortunate some of the
big big names in financial journalism at
the new york times just completely
missed it it's really unfortunate the la
times
which should have been all over this uh
because after all it happened and la
just never had a clue i mean they had
one or two halfway decent stories about
the size of the secret milk and
partnerships but they never really had a
clue how many people were affected
how many people lost money everyone in
america lost money because
everyone because he except for the
inside players except for a few hundred
or a thousand inside players everyone
lost money because 55 drexel controlled
or influenced snl's failed seized by the
rtc the loss to the taxpayers in making
up the losses to the depositors was in
excess of 10 billion dollars i or at
least roughly might have been slightly
more
might have been somewhat somewhat
substantially more but the taxpayers
have to eat that loss they have to pay
for it so every taxpayer has to cough up
some money for that then they're the
people whose pensions were invested in
milk and junk they lost a lot of money
people whose uh save was wearing junk
bond funds they lost money people whose
insurance benefits were imperiled or
reduced substantially because of the
losses in milk and junk lots and lots of
people lost money
at one point you paint a picture of
people walking into the lobby of one of
the savings alone and have a desk there
and you can walk up and buy some junk
bonds well that was keating charles
keating had a gig
where at the in the last stages of his
empire when he had lost so much money in
drexel junk and in bad real estate who's
desperately short of money he concocted
a scheme to sell junk bonds directly not
through brokers not even through drexel
to his own depositors and when his
elderly depositors would come in and try
to renew their their certificates of
deposit he would have salesmen and sales
women who would say to them buy our
american continental corporation
debentures instead they pay much more
interest and they're just as safe as
federally insured deposits
well they turned out to be a catastrophe
they they went down to almost zero the
elderly depositors lost almost
everything now it's been there have been
some major judgments in court against uh
keating and the insurers and as we've
been the accountant so i think those
bondholders will get back most of what
they lost and in fact they might get
back all of what they lost but they're
an awful lot of people who won't get it
back and the taxpayers will never get it
back
see so this the scam was a very very
clever scam it was not it was not a scam
of dumb people the scam was
we go to the buyers and we say
here is our drexel junk it yields a very
high interest rate yields say five
percentage points more than treasury and
the buyer
if he's not totally bribed to
insensitivity says or to insensibility
says but aren't they called junk for a
reason don't they default fairly often
and he said yes they default more than
treasuries which don't default ever
but at least not so far dogwood but he
said
they'll default at a rate so low
that the amount of interest that i pay
you that excess interest will more than
offset
the losses on default
so it's like as if it's like as if
you're in a fraternity let's say and you
loan money to all the other people in
your fraternity and they and you said
well some of them are going to default
but i'm charging so much interest to the
others
that that interest will more than offset
the defaults well that's what milken
said i will he said i'll have some
defaults i agree i'll have more defaults
than you would have if you had treasury
bonds or investment grade bonds i don't
deny it but they'll be so low relative
to the increased interest that you'll
come out way ahead you say 35 percent of
the bonds defaulted oh much more than
that
well i mean it depends on how you count
it let me say it depends on how you
count if you can't just default it would
be roughly 35 percent maybe rough
between 30 and 35 percent let me see if
i understand this so i let's say i went
to drexel and i put some of my money
into these bonds right if you bought a
diversified portfolio of all the drexel
bonds issued between say 83 and 90 when
they folded roughly 35 percent of them
would have defaulted by and by by uh 91.
so if i put 10 000 into but bonds went
into the office right down the street
here and said here's 10 000 i want to
buy some bonds that
you would have lost roughly 35 percent
of them would have defaulted
now they don't go to zero when they
default they go to maybe
40 or 30 on average so that you don't
lose all that but then an awful lot of
them would have been maybe another 30
would have been exchanged
for stock so and the stock would often
turn out to be valueless and you would
certainly not get any interest on the
stock uh another the others which were
successful and he did have some
companies that were not failures
they would often call in their bonds if
they were successful they would say well
gosh we're not going to keep paying the
super high interest we'll call them in
and we'll issue some lower paying
interest bonds
so lower interest paying bonds so if you
bought a huge diversified portfolio of
milk and junk you would not come out
ahead in fact but because of the
defaults and exchanges and calls you
would come out way behind where you
would have come out as you bought other
kinds of bonds
me so so what happened was the milken
people bought these bonds like the first
executive
or uh
lincoln savings send trust mutual
benefit
ben franklin savings what santa barbara
says all over the country
city fed in new jersey all over the
country and they they have in their
portfolio say a hundred million dollars
worth of bonds of drexel bonds or a
billion dollars worth average interest
rate 14
so they're booking these huge amounts of
interest payments as income
but they're not setting up any kind of
reserve for defaults
had they set up appropriate reserves for
defaults they would have shown very low
earnings
but they would not have defaulted
it's the equivalent it's like it's the
equivalent of a person who's earning
money earning money all his life earning
money spending every penny not putting
aside any reserve for the fact that at
some point he'll probably retire not
work and have to have some money
essentially the milk and captive buyers
the snl's
the insurers the junk bond funds were
doing that they were booking this huge
amount of income but not taking reserves
for the defaults which were rolling and
rolling and rolling in they would take
charges some of them for unrealized
losses but they would not take them as
deductions against income it was
fantastic accounting fraud
i know that sounds boring i'm sorry
but it's very important because
accounting
everyone thinks accounting is boring
and i think what they're really getting
confused about is that accountants are
often boring but accounting
for those of a criminal turn of mind is
the absolutely
most
lucrative exciting adventurous glamorous
place to be uh when you look at the
again the structure of government uh you
also talked about the government
accounting office
that uh general accounting office the
so-called watchdog agency of congress
which was so captured by milken
they were it was amazing they were like
the
government agency equivalent of uh
patricia hurst i mean turning into an
actual fighter for the symbionese
liberation army i mean they were
supposed to be supervising
the federal deposit insurance fund
they came out in 1989 with a report
endorsing the purchase and holding of
junk bonds by federally insured snls
they used only drexel-supplied drexel
endorsed drexel-affiliated experts for
their report
did not do any independent investigation
of their own of default rates
and when a year later 11 of the 12 snls
they'd cited as examples of great
examples of junk bond holding snls had
failed and i spoke to the author of the
report he said he wouldn't change a
thing
can this all happen again oh yes oh yes
and will
and will because you may be sure
that the stakes for government forgot
any government bureaucrat in undoing
this fraud or stopping the fraud are far
smaller than the stakes for the people
perpetrating the fraud now milton
friedman a solid genius guy
for his mathematical work on monetarism
and other things also has a very
wonderful theory
of how
government and influence on government
works and it is that the smaller the
number of people trying to influence the
government policy
the large greater effect they will have
because the results will be so large for
each individual person that he will he
or she will exert enormously more effort
than the large group of people who are
more or less indifferent and that would
include government bureaucrats the
the gs14
who is supposed to be watching what
milken's doing
it's a government great pay grade gets
paid whether or not the fraud is busted
the milken player who puts this fraud
over on the government
does not get paid if the fraud is busted
but gets millions and maybe hundreds of
millions if the fraud goes ahead but as
a system of checks and balances we've
touched on john diegel dingle was good
he did not go far enough but he was the
one who first exposed the fact that
milken was controlling the price of the
bonds that milk would take say bonds of
let's say mgm or
uh some other or golden nugget or
somebody like that and he would in the
same morning he'd sell them to all
different people at different prices
just whatever price he felt like selling
them at and what what he was the first
one to expose that milk would for
example
sell a bond he would take a bond from
the issuer and he would buy it in a
milken family trust
for
say
a little bit above the offering price
and then he would immediately resell it
for a huge percentage profit on an
annualized basis say to first executive
then a first executive wanted to sell
he would buy it back from them at a loss
and resell it to another drexel captive
and another huge profit so that he was
controlling the price for the benefit of
him
his top players and insiders and
partners and to the detriment of his
fiduciaries his customers i'm sorry it's
trust stores as customers but going to
go back to the system of checks and
balances you have the congressional
committees the press you talk about the
press was a complete failure except for
barons
the general accounting office
another government agency
the securities and exchange commission
an almost complete failure they did
eventually indict milk and on 98 felony
counts but they were i have to say that
the milk and people always say well
these were trivial accounts and i have
to say compared with what he really did
they worked for you but in the end you
give credit to a college professor
a business school professor the
professor asquith who was uh
then at harvard is now at mit
who did the studies their first studies
that showed that the directional junk
was defaulting at a much higher rate
than drexel had claimed
much much higher rate
drexel had its own captive academics who
would put out these studies using all
kinds of very questionable methodology
about the default rates he was the first
one who applied appropriate methodology
got it publicized adequately and really
i think put the nails in the coffin
um back to the acknowledgement so we
started with your father who you give a
lot of credit to then you mentioned your
mother my mother's mildred stein also
very very smart and very very very smart
and very witty as well what did she do
for your book
she read it and uh she uh
she she was very skeptical of it i have
to say her
her skepticism about my view of it
prompted me to do a great deal more
research and thinking about the entire
template than i might otherwise have
done and in the end was she for you on
this side oh she's very much for me but
she thinks this is
okay
well i mean she wishes i had been a
doctor so
she's she'd still rather i was a doctor
but she's very proud of this book what
does she do for a living
she is a housewife and uh
and uh collector of newspapers and also
uh
and also she helps my father with his
books and his writing and uh
she isn't she's a very successful and a
small scale investor in stocks i mean
she's very good at that she has a
certain she has some wonderful success
stories what government jobs have have
you has your father had
well he started in 1937 at the federal
deposit insurance corporation he worked
i think i may have this wrong but i
think for the war production board he
was in the navy during world war ii
who's a ensign and then i think a second
lieutenant
and then he worked for a very long time
for about 20 years for the committee for
economic development he was research
director it's a businessman's group that
in those days was absolutely at the
forefront of
responsible conservative free-market
approaches to economic problems and he
wrote many many wonderful reports and
studies and policy papers for them he's
he's an extraordinary genius i mean
he's not just a genius as an economist
but although that would be plenty but as
a political thinker and a social thinker
and uh
i mean he's just an incredibly witty
smart guy where is he now
well he's at the american enterprise
institute which is a think tank in
washington and uh just an amazing guy i
mean to talk to him is really sort of
like going on a roller coaster he's so
smart but he was chairman of the council
he was chairman i hadn't gotten to that
yet he was chairman of the council of
economic advisers for a time under nixon
then very briefly under ford he was a
member under chairman paul mccracken uh
for uh
for a few years or a couple years before
he became chairman my sister rachel she
is a writer in new york and uh
a great win and rachel
uh she's my older sister she doesn't
look as she looks younger
she uh
she
came up with an amazing piece of
analysis which really was just
mind-blowing which was
see i'm part of the clinton generation i
use phrase like mind-blowing um she said
uh i know the worst almost every bob
dylan song so i think i should be
chairman of the sec
so he uh
she i was talking to her oh 10 years ago
maybe i said well why is it i think do
you think there's so much more financial
fraud than there used to be is it
because of the inflation rate is it
because of a change in regulatory
climate and she said it's because
there's so many more criminals working
on wall street that's why
and and that really opened my eyes that
the problem was a problem of individual
unethical people
doing these things it wasn't so much a
problem of giant macroeconomic trends
but of an ethical collapse
do you have a political philosophy that
you follow today
well i like to think of myself as a
compassionate conservative i mean i have
a lot of sympathy for people who are
poor who are homeless who are who are
handicapped by various things including
perceptions of racism
and uh
i do think that the country spends much
too little on the least fortunate among
us and i think
too much is spent by the most fortunate
among us and
an awful lot of the money that goes for
very fancy cars and for beautiful homes
and for plastic surgery would be better
off frankly being taken by the
government and used to improve education
health care and
drug rehabilitation and law enforcement
for poor people i think this country
spends much too little on maintaining
itself as a society
confused a little bit when i hear you
talk about you wrote the book about
hollywood and the politics out here and
what they're giving us on television yet
you stay here you live it you're in the
movies you consider yourself a
compassionate conservative but does your
ideology track with most of people that
live here no no no it tracks i think
with most of the people
who live here at least a lot of them it
doesn't attract with many of the people
in the entertainment business but the
people in the entertainment business are
pretty uh
they're very ideologically monolithic
are tend to be anyway but they also tend
to have a certain amount of tolerance
for the occasional eccentric like yours
truly who comes along and pitches things
i i've had really i think considering
the fact that i am
i think probably the only person who
likes nixon and the entire writer's
guild
i think i've had some extraordinary
successes here as a writer and
provider of ideas to hollywood and i
will say that
i don't think i'm ever going to be in
the hollywood inner circle for a lot of
reasons one of some of which are
ideological but
hollywood is a generous open-minded
place in many ways at least at least it
has been to me i mean it could have been
more so but overall it's been very good
to me mention before we went on the
other people don't drink much here well
uh yeah i was comparing with washington
where i grew up and where i often visit
and with new york it never fails to
amaze me when i go out to lunch with
people in new york and i have a drink or
a couple of drinks at lunch that's
unheard of in hollywood it's it's not
done it just isn't done it's not that it
occasionally happens it never happens
people in hollywood have many many vices
but they're they tend to be extremely
health-conscious and extremely
abstemious about alcohol extremely i
mean it's an amazing thing you go into
morton's which is a very powerful and
wonderful restaurant here
and
in one part of the room are all the
showbiz people
and they're like drinking grape juice or
drinking apple juice or drinking
soda water and then you go to the other
part of the room where the visiting
investment bankers and the visiting
lawyers are out here on business from
chicago or new york are they're slamming
down drinks slamming down drinks and
then they're the tourists say from
england or from germany and they're like
just pouring it straight from the tank
down their throats and then people in
hollywood are just sitting there and you
can always tell the people from
hollywood don't drink and they don't
smoke
they're abstemious they're health
conscious
they want to live forever you ever want
to come back to washington
i'd really love to come back to
washington if i could live there
and live so i could see my parents every
day
i would love that a lot and see my old
friends from high school i would love
that a lot but i i do love my acting i
go back there quite a lot and
i think i will get an apartment there if
income permits so i can just spend more
time i love being around my parents
they're very very smart funny people
why do you love the acting
well uh
i
for most of my life was not paid to be
me
i essentially just act as me
i mean i don't you know i can't play
hamlet i don't expect to ever play
hamlet i don't expect to ever play a
paratrooper or a cowboy
but
i never got paid to be me before i got
paid to do work but they pay me not very
much but enough to be me that's a
fantastic gig
you work with very friendly nice people
there's never such a thing as people
being in a bad mood on the set
uh you usually have a lot of attention
paid do you have somebody doing your
hair obviously not a big thing in my
case have somebody doing your makeup
your wardrobe it's just friendly it's
like being at camp it's like being at
summer camp a particularly cheerful one
or being in a very large friendly family
only you get paid for it
i hate to leave the set i mean i
doing this work was interesting and
challenging and hard work and i really
it's my life i dream about it almost
every night but
acting is just a gift it's acting as
just
bliss
in this book you talk about uh being
roughed up by the pr machine of michael
milken
yeah very cruelly and and very foolishly
on their part the
they they have floated a whole series of
just bizarre things about me one that i
wanted to work for michael milken which
was just using snippets of a letter i
sent to milken and a whole bunch of
other investment bankers asking them if
i could go over some of their deals
before they made them public so i could
explain to them what the ethical
problems were and i said in return what
i'd like to do is interview a whole
bunch of your younger people and get an
idea of their ethical standards
and this letter which everybody else
ignored i have to say was i sent it to
morgan stanley and goldman sachs and a
whole bunch of other people everybody
else ignored it but the drexel people
tried to use it to show sour grapes that
i wasn't working for them that's why i
wrote the book and i may say
i think that was always preposterous
because suppose i had applied for the
job and suppose they had turned me down
and suppose i had written it out of sour
grips which i did not but suppose i had
even so it has a tremendous amount of
factual material in it that would have
to be disproved to disprove my analysis
of the case they can't just say
ben stein you're a creep to disprove my
analysis
so but they keep thinking that they can
um
then they
they
picked up a bizarre story of me being a
potential airplane hijacker just an
incredible story so crazy that it's hard
to even conceive of and they floated
that around
how did that come from
well it came from a a an incident in
which i was we used to have a vacation
house in santa cruz and there had been
prowlers in the neighborhood and i was
shipping a gun up to santa cruz to keep
in my house i had a big argument there
with them at the airport about how the
means of shipping the gun and so forth
but it was an unloaded gun i mean there
nobody ever thought it was for hijacking
it was an issue of how the gun should be
shipped
but it was uh but a preposterous
preposterous sort of a series of
allegations then because i had written
an article in the new york times op-ed
page about why i didn't think president
bush former president bush should use
halcyon
you know powerful sleeping pill that he
was reported to have used
and i said i had been prescribed and i
had found a very very dangerous drug
others of course like it but i found it
a very dangerous drug i said i didn't
think the president should be using it
they picked that up to say that i'm a
drug addict one of milken's lawyers was
on a radio talk show not long ago saying
i was a drug addict just because of that
and
very mean remarks about my wife which i
don't want to even repeat on the air but
just absolutely unfounded totally made
up cruel remarks but you did it right
about those things in the book about
your wife well
well taken point okay well i will say
then that they uh
they misquote
a woman with whom i was once in
litigation a famous comedian named joan
rivers
to the effect that my wife was a lesbian
which is a totally made-up
untrue
comment i have nothing
whatsoever against lesbians and they're
very very productive members of this
communist hollywood community but uh
but i don't but the idea that my wife
was ever one is just unbelievably wrong
and just was a device to try to upset
and smear me it's an amazing thing i
have written hundreds of thousands by
this point maybe a million words about
drexel
very very detailed stuff about bond
default rates about rates of default
offset by yields on bonds i've never
ever once gotten a factual rebuttal from
the milk and pr machine all i've gotten
is ad hominem smears from the pr machine
and from the legal machine but the
article you did write about joan rivers
that turned into a lawsuit right well
that was a terrible mistake on my part i
should never have written it but i was
as is as is in deposition so i don't
think i'm sharing confidence i was told
a story by several different people
about a whole bunch of very witty funny
things joan rivers had said at a uh
memorial shiva for her departed husband
in the late 80s and i wrote them up
under a pseudonym in gq i was asked to
write about them i said i thought they
should have somebody else right and they
said well you just write about it under
a pseudonym
and uh what's gq gq is a magazine a very
popular slick sheet magazine in large
part about men's fashions but it's about
a lot of things what was your pseudonym
and that meant
you know something i don't i think it
was bert hacker
a name i some some real person actually
has and i read i was terribly amused by
it
and uh
but i thought actually the remarks were
quite funny and uh didn't show her is
doing anything but being funny and witty
which she is obviously a very witty
woman let me she sued over it and uh
she's sued for libel i think i should
just finish this one thing which is
she dropped the suit after not very long
apologized to me for even questioning my
honesty and integrity i also apologize
to gq
somehow that part of her apologizing for
questioning my honesty and integrity
never gets picked up
by
by the milken people the part that she
sued me gets picked up the fact that she
dropped it doesn't somehow get picked up
let me just throw one other thing in
there she now today has a gossip program
on the usa network where they sit around
just talk about gossip it's hard for
probably some people to understand
what's going on in a town like this well
you write an article
well because i it is my belief that
she sued me largely as a publicity stunt
her career was in trouble at that time
she uh
she wanted to make herself look
sympathetic she got on tv and cried
she did look sympathetic and frankly i
regret having written the article
because it got me into a lot of hot
water with people who don't understand
about humor about libel law
but
one of the defenses we actually
produced to the court and this is in
public papers as well is
that she was libel proof because in this
area because we had said no more than
she had a devilishly sharp wit
and that since she had earned a very
lavish living for many years having a
devilishly sharp wit especially making
fun of family members in her act
she could not then sue saying joan
rivers you have a very sharp wit and you
make fun of family members
amazingly to show you how courts work in
america the judge in the case dismissed
that saying
i don't believe that joan rivers is
something i'm not quoting for babe is a
friend of mine and we're on the same
charitable boards and i'm sure she
wouldn't say anything like that
this is a judge so
beware of beware of being in court
altogether as my humble thought about
all this you mentioned earlier in this
talk that a lot of your old colleagues
are now in the clinton administration
evaluate that administration
uh he's obviously a terribly smart guy
the wife is obviously terribly smart um
i think he's got a fairly high powered
group of people around him i think it's
disgraceful that ron brown was appointed
with so little
thought about his connections and the
kind of people he works for and i think
the kind of man he is
but
i think he's terribly smart and means
well and my thought for us republicans
is
we shouldn't start sniping at him right
away just let's give him a little chance
to see if he can do something we have
real problems in this country it's a
cinch
that we republicans have not solved them
it's a sense that a lot of them have
gotten worse while we republicans were
in office
so i think it is not unreasonable to
give the democrats a little bit of a
room to try out their solutions and see
if they work i mean
it's obviously not true that republicans
and conservatives have all the answers
maybe the democrats do have some answers
let's let's hope it works
assess the impact this town hollywood
movies television programs are having on
the country
well i think that they generally
speaking have
i think generally speaking tv has a
questionable effect because it distracts
people from reading studying being with
their family you're learning human
schools human skills of communication
and compassion it's sort of like
uh
what what would you think would happen
to a country which people instead of
spending time with their family instead
of learning to read instead of learning
about the wider world through reading
instead of taking care of their children
are glued to a television screen
obviously by its very nature television
has a kind of
questionable impact
i think tv promotes some very good
values i think tv is extremely
pro-family extremely there's no other
medium that's ever endorsed the family
unit however constituted and the idea of
love and nurture of those within it
anywhere near as much as tv has excuse
me i think tv is very much pro-integrity
and honesty it really slams people
who don't have good morals it's very
anti-business and teaches that business
is corrupt and difficult unfortunately
that's often very largely true
especially in finance i don't think it's
as true in other areas as it is in
finance
i think it teaches that work is the
sucker's way out and school work is
really for losers and nerds and geeks
and that's a really bad thing i think if
you watch the shows which show students
and young people only the losers do
their school work the winners do not do
their schoolwork the winners finesse it
by some kind of contracts
i think that's bad attitude simon and
schuster published this book of yours
and this is what it looks like to show
the audience uh how's it doing
it's doing pretty well i mean it's not a
raging bestseller but it's doing pretty
well when it gets out into the new
bookstores people buy it and learn from
it and i think it's for like it's a two
hour three hour read for for a decent
reader you really get a whole new idea
of how america is american finance and
business runs and about gigantic
failures in american life have you heard
from the milken organization since
you've published this book
well i heard from it in the sense that
one of milken's lawyers was on a local
talk show saying don't believe a word
you wrote about this guy who's a drug
addict this this based on the fact that
i wrote that for a week i had been
prescribed halcyon
for a uh
for insomnia and uh so i've heard from
them in that way i haven't heard from
them in any kind of direct way
you know michael milken is reported to
have been in narcotics anonymous when he
was in prison which is a program a
12-step program for people who
are uh narcotics addicts the book that
said that also said he was not a
narcotics addict and i have no reason to
doubt that that's so um but if he's
really in that program he has to promise
to turn his will and his life over to
god and to make a new start ethically in
his life
and
it may well be that he has i i
would question that based upon the work
that his publicists have
his lawyer recently did on me but
i hope and pray that that's true he's
obviously a man of great ability
obviously a very persuasive man it's
obvious the government isn't going to go
after him in any serious way the rtc did
sue him alleging a conspiracy almost
identical to what i described in the
book and he settled for 900 million but
i think he's uh
if he can change and pull himself
together he's going to be a real local
asset for us here in southern california
two quick questions the
six or seven movies you're in which ones
you get the most reaction from ferris
bueller's day off by far second
honeymoon in vegas third soap dish
next book for you
next book is a book about the financial
misconduct and
just as a general thing it's for the
20th century fund and i'm very close to
being done with it this is what the book
looks like it's called a license to
steal by benjamin j stein all about mike
milken thank you very much for joining
us thank you very very much
for a transcript of this edition of book